herman le françois cluzet emporté engagé
qui ne mâche pas ses mots qui a son
franc parler bien sûr vous vous en êtes
fait quelques-uns de lucchini ah ah oui
c'est des cons c'est des congés rien
d'autre à dire sont des cons sont des
cons ce sont des voix là vous voyez ce
match pas mes mots encore ni sur les
cons je vais vous dire ça m'arrive
d'être combat et ça m'est arrivé
peut-être plusieurs plus + 2 fois que
courtney ce sont les cons parce que il
saute sur l'occasion de la pandémie l'un
pour dire mais l'hautil le restaurateur
ilab les couteaux mais ferme ta gueule
et bien prêt ou pas mais je regrette pas
je le pense ouvertement ce sont des
mégalos et l'autre abruti deux premiers
qui se présente président de la
république en disant allez tous vous
faire mais ça va pas la tête non mais
ils viennent d'où ces mecs là ils ont un
ego comme un gratte-ciel et qu'ils nous
foutent la paix on est suffisamment dans
la mer qui nous donne de l'espoir y en a
pas un qui donne de l'espoir sont tous
là à dire d'étudier des dida mais ta
gueule ferme-la et puis tonnes ce que tu
as à donner ne vient pas nous donner tes
tête au prurit
cérébrale les kinés bigard c'est vrai
merde on est des acteurs on est au
service du public et on est là pour leur
apprendre la joie et leur offrir quelque
chose on n'est pas là pour se montrer en
disant oui mais le gouvernement est
tellement sont fous écrasent sous un
gouvernement qui est au gouvernement tu
la veux la place donc ça m'insupporte
pas maintenant mais ont le sourire
j'ai fait un numéro j'ai fait un peu mon
numéro pour vous dire que je suis vif
avec l'aîné diallo parce qu'en plus ces
gens là ne donne pas une bonne idée de
nous autres interprètes ont de dieu nous
sommes des interprètes nous ne sommes
pas seuls en scène nous sommes des
partenaires aucun des deux n'est un
partenaire il ne donne rien à l'autre je
le sais j'ai joué avec eux il ne donne
rien donc s'ils ne donnent rien aux
partenaires ya rien résultat des courses
le public n'a rien pourquoi parce que ce
sont des égocentriques nombrilisme et
gallo je ne sais pas quoi mais
franchement il donne une image de ce
métier
épouvantable alors que moi la chance que
j'ai c'est que je connais les grands
artistes du théâtre et du site emma je
les connais je les fréquente et j'essaye
d'apporter mon tout petit pierre à
l'édifice tant que le film soit réussie
et non pas à montrer ma gueule en disant
vous avez vu vous avez vu vous a eu et
puis avec ses 7 déversement de cérébral
d'intellectualisme et de lectures et de
lectures et de lectures et de lectures
et de lecture ou et what what et alors
tu as lu tous les bouquins du monde et
ça ne t'a pas donné l'humanité ça ne t'a
pas donné la générosité balante aurait
mieux fait de ne pas les lire françois
cluzet cette vérité cette colère on
l'entend et le public vous aime beaucoup
pour ça mais non juste franc parler dont
je m'excuse de m'énerver parce que je
vous le dis c'est un peu un numéro
d'acteur donc je suis franc je reste
entier mais je ne supporte pas les gens
qui ne donne rien et qui reçoit beaucoup
varié relate ou l'extrait 1 voilà c'est
par émission d'ailleurs
merci le pauvre hantise humaines les
deux oui merci donc c'est vrai que j'ai
dit le pont ce que j'adore 35 l'uzège
toc c'est un artiste formidable
j'aimerais beaucoup être son ami j'ai
déjà dit mais bon là et ils se tirent
tous saluent une balle dans le pied il
fait une crise de nerfs il est très très
en colère je vais dire et je sais pas
j'ai pas tué le chien quoi je m'excuse
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pourquoi
pourquoi quoi pour le chien un con
d'ailleurs il est très possible que je
sois un con ce qui n'exclut pas non plus
que je suis aussi très intelligent et
très gentil tu vois ça n'a rien à voir
donc un conte se veut dire quoi être un
conte et en plus je me retrouve dans le
box des accusés avec fabrice luchini
alors là c'est la médaille quoi pour moi
c'est c'est mon oscar à moi quoi attends
je suis sur le banc à côté de fabrice
luchini le bonheur total qu'on peut
qu'on ne peut pas traiter de con par
fabrice luchini moi d'accord bon c'est
vrai mais c'est vrai j'ai des
convictions
comme gilles par exemple met en pétard
si souvent s'il croit quelque chose il y
va c'est au fousseret tu vois et c'est
vrai que j'ai un peu tendance à faire ça
ça me coûte cher et il a raison très
souvent je pourrais fermer ma gueule
mais mais qu'est-ce qu'on serait sans
les gens qui ouvrent un peu leur gueule
et ce qui aurait eu la révolution
française est ce qu'il y aurait eu la
commune tu vois ce qu'ils ont tout d'un
coup dit non parce que il ne supportait
pas quelque chose moi j'ai un problème
est qu'un justice donc c'est très facile
de m'allumer un tu frottes deux cailloux
dans la cour et ej sous le feu notre
dame tu vois pas ce que je suis je suis
comme ça j'ai beaucoup de mal à fermer
ma gueule que je ressens une injustice
et la
françois crise et encore une fois que
que j'adore et je t'adore montclus clu
mon truc lui à moi et faut absolument
qu'on aille boire une camomille tous les
deux
ça va nous détendre je te jure parce que
moi mais ce record est venu jeudi en
plus jean-marie mois les personnages
comme ça même si voilà la série qui dit
que ça mais on adore c'est si rare et
l'a tellement c'est tellement rare les
métaux lourds gueule quand même de rien
même exactement ami à lui qui dit y en a
plus mais comme ça donc c'est vrai que
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est aussi
c'est ça c'est un kiff d'avoir un mec
comme ça qu'ils qui osent non
versailleux ouais bien sûr il demande à
à moi de fermer ma gueule que je suis
taillé pour l'ouvrir mais non c'est sûr
que il va il va m'accuser
de voir ma gueule mais je peux moi aussi
de chair de l'ouvrir quelquefois est
très souvent dans la rue je veux c'est
qu'il sache ce qu'il dit il a l'air de
dire que nous sommes des moins que rien
j'ai un rêve je sais que fabrice luchini
n'a pas envie du tout de laisser une
suite à quoi que ce soit qui trouve
comme moi que c'est lamentable ce qu'il
a fait c'est juste
ridiculiser tout seul a pas besoin de de
l'attaqué pas l'attaquer en justice pour
pour injures publiques mais et je lui en
fais cadeau un ces injures publiques ces
dix mille balles par deux ses vingt
mille matois il passe même pas par la
case départ
était il est exonéré de 20000 donc qu'il
soit qu'il soit gentil je voudrais dire
importe bout par exemple de fabrice
luchini comment on peut réduire
une personne en disant ballon il a lu il
a lu les rives des livres délire et
alors
tu vas regarde là je m'énerve ouais et
alors le jeu rappelait
la france soit prise et que de lire les
livres comme le fait
fabrice luchini c'est qu'il nous
rappelle tout simplement à tous et pour
tous le métier que le plus important
c'est le compteur
ce n'est pas l'histoire moi qui suis un
gros rat conteur de blague c'est le
conteur le plus important moi je fais
une blague sublime avec une blague
pourrie et je donne n'importe quelle
blague sublime à est morte mais qu'ils
veulent à chier par terre par terre
juste ben oui c'est vrai mais c'est là
c'est
mais c'est
bien sûr c'est le fric il y avait de
tout temps depuis des milliers d'années
tu as la maison des palabres la tribu
s'est réuni là il ya un conteur et le
compteur tu peux pas savoir quelle
importance si là il arrive toute la
tribu et là il se met à raconter
lille et j'en rigole on rigole on rigole
il arrive à une conclusion très souvent
qui qu'il improvise un phrase après
phrase et quand il a terminé tout le
monde applaudit et d'uzès qui lui
demande de lui dire on raconte à nous
parce que c'est la qualité du conteur
qu'elle est plus importante fabrice
luchini que tu nous lis que c'est saint
victor hugo balzac ou autre il nous
montre le coeur de l'auteur c'est très
important